in any case the night has better uses
then sleep
hi there its senior editor Kevin van Ord
standing in for reviewer Miguel
concepción to tell you about Assassin's
Creed 3 liberation HD Assassin's Creed 3
liberation for the Vita fell short of
its potential but was still an
impressive showcase for open-world play
on a portable platform now you can play
a high-definition release on the Xbox
360 and PlayStation 3 and it looks
pretty nice about as well as you would
expect for an HD upgrade of a Vita game
as for the gameplay well it's exactly
the same including Liberation's original
bugs liberation follows the exploits of
aveline de gran prey the franchise's
first playable female assassin the
majority of aveline's missions are
fundamentally recognizable to Assassin's
Creed players right down to the tailing
and escort missions her objectives in
the Louisiana bayou mirror
Connors missions in the woods of
Assassin's Creed 3 with aveline
sprinting across large tree branches
while stalking hostiles on the ground
Liberation's disguise system is its most
unique feature the ability to Don the
personas of a socialite a slave and an
assassin is reflective of aveline's
complicated background as the daughter
of a French merchant and a slave
moreover her ability to charm powerful
men is another asset that other
assassins lacked the benefits of playing
liberation on consoles are best
appreciated in combat it's more
comfortable to play on a Playstation 3
or Xbox 360 controller versus the
confined button layout of the Vita the
exploitable convenience of the
Assassin's Creed smoke bomb still lets
you skewer up to four enemies at once
without interruption but Aveline is so
brutal in her use of weapons like the
sugarcane machete that you might be
inclined to forego bombs just to watch
her in defense
action liberation cinematics have been
overhauled to the point that you don't
need to hold up the Vita version to tell
the differences between the initial
release and the new one in fact the
changes in skin tone eyes and other
facial features are so significant that
depending on the lighting and camera
angles some characters don't even want
like their video starts roaming New
Orleans and higher resolution is
impressive even though liberation
doesn't achieve the same level of detail
of Assassin's Creed games originally
designed for consoles
if you thought Ubisoft might have taken
the opportunity to fix some bugs and
other issues during the remastering
process well think again and while this
game retains the series notoriety system
it's easy to avoid confrontation guards
are very slow to react when a Valene is
nearby even when she's speed walking in
her restrictive socialite outfit this
ease of play not only speaks to
liberation hd's low difficulty level but
also to the lack of incentives to
deviate from the storyline the game
isn't short of side missions which
include a footrace the theft of a ship
and the freeing of slaves but liberation
HD does a poor job and letting you know
that these missions exist especially
when the game doesn't put financial
hurdles that force you to raise funds
and take a break from the story
attaching HD to a previously released
game often means you're getting a
high-definition remaster rather than a
remake with visuals reconstructed from
the ground up judging by the quality of
the cutscenes developer Ubisoft Sofia
aspired to the latter but ended up with
the former considering the time and care
they put into those cinematics it's
disappointing the gameplay in its bugs
didn't receive the same level of
attention meet again away our ray of
jorik familiar
you
[Music]